bonjour il ya très exactement un an
monsieur marc blondel le 1er mai 1993 je
vous avais téléphoné pour vous demander
de venir témoigner à l'heure de vérité
c'était au soir du suicide de monsieur
bérégovoy et nous avions décidé
évidemment de bouleverser nos programmes
du lendemain alors ce soir là vous
m'aviez dit non car vous vous sentiez
trop proche de lui trop touché
personnellement par le drame alors un an
s'est écoulé et en ce jour anniversaire
jean marie colombani va vous demander de
nous parler de monsieur bérégovoy auquel
le président de la république a rendu ce
matin vous le savez hommage à nevers non
non nous vous demandons de nous parler
de l'homme du ministre de son bilan
social aussi alors nous parlerons bien
sûr aussi de ce qui s'est passé depuis
que monsieur pierre bérégovoy nous a
acquitté et notamment de son successeur
de monsieur balladur et de ses relations
avec le monde du travail
vous nous donnerez votre avis sur ce qui
s'est dit aussi hier à la journée de
réflexion sur le chômage et l'emploi du
rpr qui s'est tenue à port marly
est-ce que nous allons à votre avis vers
un changement de politique économique
dans le cadre de la campagne pour
l'élection présidentielle de tout ça
nous parlerons avec colombani ensuite
michel noblecourt du monde vous
interrogera sur les projets de lois de
madame simone veil -le ceux qui sont
passés au dernier conseil des ministres
à mentières et ceux qui ne sont pas
passés sur la protection sociale en
général comment voyez-vous l'équilibré
de l'assurance maladie
l'avenir des retraites les acquis
sociaux d'un siècle de syndicalisme sont
ils vraiment menacée et que ferez vous
que ferez vous force ouvrière s'ils le
sont je rappelle que force ouvrière se
prépare à fêter le centième anniversaire
de la naissance de la cgt en 1895 à
limoges cgt dont vous êtes vous aussi
les rich et alors on essaiera de
replacer un petit peu votre action
actuelle dans le cadre historique et
notamment par a certainement de vos
relations aux frères siamois de la cgt
or il ya les que le mes qui se
mondialise aussi monsieur
les en même temps que les syndicats
donnent l'impression de camper sur des
positions très étroitement nationale
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un peu en
retard d'une guerre
et de quel poids pèse rond les syndicats
français leur héritage historique que
vous apprêtez à célébrer leur maigre
bataillon de militants quand la
concurrence deviendra vraiment mondiale
ce qu'elle n'est pas encore puisque la
chine et la plupart des pays du tiers
monde ne sont pas encore engagés dans le
développement économique de tout ça en
parlera avec albert des rois par là
aussi de l'europe des usines qui
quittent le territoire français pour
aller s'installer par exemple en en
irlande de l'absence de cette politique
sociale européenne
où en êtes-vous monsieur blondel de
votre grand projet de droit social
européen et bien sûr avec la perspective
de l'élection du nouveau parlement de
strasbourg bien on parlera des listes et
notamment de l'entrée fracassante sur la
scène politique française de monsieur
bernard tapie alors on commence avec
jean marie colombani
jeu blanc belle bonjour bonjour monsieur
bombes adhésives et je me félicite
d'être interrogé par le patron du
journal le monde
c'est une façon de le dire ta tion de le
féliciter
c'est donc françois henry a évoqué
pierre bérégovoy quel bilan vous même
faites vous avec le recul maintenant de
pierre bérégovoy
on sait que c'était l'homme du franc
fort on sait que c'était l'homme de la
victoire contre l'inflation
et pourtant on sait que à l'époque il
était très critiqué pour cette
obstination dans cette voie alors avec
le recul est-ce que vous lui feriez les
mêmes reproches de ce qu'on lui faisait
à l'époque
évidemment j'entends tenait avec pierre
bérégovoy des relations personnelles qui
étaient dues à une amitié de trente cinq
ans j'ai milité avec lui au moment de la
guerre d'algérie tout vous dire je peux
même indiqué dans cette émission que
nous faisions partie des minorités qui
nous voulions agissant au sein de force
ouvrière de l'époque
maintenant je n'aime pas tellement les
minorités agissantes au sein de la latte
mais ça c'est de bonne guerre ces jeunes
eux et nous avions toujours gardé il est
resté fidèle à l'organisation syndicale
et nous avions toujours gardé de
relations amicales y compris au moment
où il a fait de la politique et qu'il
est devenu premier ministre mais
préalablement aussi ministre des
finances secrétaire général du
gouvernement et c'est cette relation
julian n'a pas empêché que chacun dans
vos positions lui preuve une issue vous
syndicaliste n'était pas pas d'accord
sur le sur le cap à suivre bien sûr
c'est la raison pour laquelle je dirais
même non seulement ça n'a pas empêché
mais de temps en temps ça a développé
les preuves des accords parce que nous
voulions ni lui ni moi nous laisser
emmener par nos relations amicales donc
de temps en temps c'est être nm j'étais
en désaccord sur la politique
restrictive
j'étais en désaccord j'avais qualifié
cette politique comme étant une
politique de rentiers ça lui avait déplu
il en a effet l'observation et j'étais
en désaccord sur la notion monétaire sur
la recherche du franc fort en permanence
c'est à dire que je mettais un point
d'interrogation sérieux sur les
convergences européennes c'est ça il
faut bien l'avouer et je crois que
bérégovoy appliquer cette politique est
régulièrement il s'interrogeait sur
cette politique ça n'était pas l'homme
s'était pas la politique qu'il aurait
souhaité appliquer il y était conduit
par les la situation européenne par la
politique économique qui était celle de
l'europe et qui ressemble être celle de
l'europe
mais je peux par exemple témoigner et je
vais faire preuve d'un petit peu
d'opportunités vous me pardonnerez il
avait été au bout d'un moment convaincu
par son cabinet et par l' ocde que le
smic était un frein à l'embauché et ils
avaient envisagé de faire le swing jeune
et je me souviens d'une conversation
matinale où pendant 20 minutes
ça a été la colère réciproque du
militant syndicaliste par rapport à son
ancien camarade syndicalisme et je crois
que je porte une petite responsabilité
sur le fait qu' il n'a pas réalisé la
chose mais ça veut dire qu'ils
rentraient bien dans une mécanique qui
étaient mécaniques de politique
restrictive et ça je pense que ça peut
être d'ailleurs une des raisons de son
interrogation
alors oui car on l'avait fait fléchir
cédant la sphère du droit de grève à la
ratp c'est vrai mais c'est faux ça vous
sauter sur toutes les occasions monsieur
oui ben là je vais profiter aussi
oui il ya eu un petit problème avec
monsieur christian blanc qui était à
l'époque le pdg de la ratp et
monsieur christian blanc avait obtenu du
premier ministre la possibilité de
mettre un service minimum à définir les
circonstances ont fait que j'ai vu le
conseiller social qui était madame
pitois pujade quelques jours avant que
la décision définitive soit confirmée et
j'ai fait à sous-entendu sur le droit de
grève et j'ai ensuite vu le premier
ministre à sa demande nous avons eu une
conversation de 15 minutes 20 minutes
coléreuse même coléreuse cette fois et
il n'a pas donné suite il a téléphoné en
disant que lyon est écrit sur blanc à
démissionner cela n'était mais enfin
aujourd'hui fayer plus exactement il ya
une petite phrase dans le discours de
jacques chirac qui consiste à dire ce
gouvernement gouvernement balladur et le
précédent gouvernement bérégovoy ont en
commun d'avoir essayé de colmater les
brèches dans le domaine de l'emploi de
la lutte contre le chômage
je voudrais savoir si ce rapprochement
en termes de politiques conduites
balladur bérégovoy vous paraît pertinent
sur le plan général et si vous diriez la
même chose de la politique de l'emploi
de l'un et de l'autre c'est à dire que
l'un comme l'autre n'ont jamais fait que
colmater les brèches
est ce que c'est un le bon diagnostic je
crois que c'est assez bien vu je crois
effectivement que ce gouvernement et les
gouvernements précédents on fait une
politique de traitement social du
chômage mais victime des orientations
économiques été choisi et j'insiste
politique monétaire est restrictive
ils n'ont pas pu relancer l'activité à
partir de ce moment là ils n'ont pas
attaqué effectivement le problème sur le
faut il alors on entend dire aujourd'hui
jacques chirac valéry giscard d'estaing
ya quelques jours les socialistes en
permanence il faut que l'emploi soit
maintenant la priorité est que tout le
reste en découle se tenait qui joue on
peut s'étonner à la fois qu'il ne l'ait
dit plus tôt et surtout qu'ils aient
considéré le chômage comme étant une
priorité j'aurais souhaité voie puisque
du tout le monde a une occasion de
s'exprimer là dessus mais surtout tu ne
prenne quelques décisions mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
justement mes côtés et qu'est ce que ça
veut dire nature se dire quoi bon je
vais essayer d'appréhender le problème
de la manière suivante nous vivons moi
j'appelle ça une révolution du temps et
de l'espace
les choses vont beaucoup plus vite que
par le passé à la fois non seulement sur
le plan temporel mais aussi sur le plan
de l'action
en gros si je voulais essayer de faire
une image on vivait d'abord à son rythme
normal quand on était fatigués on
dormait ensuite au moyen-âge et eu leur
loge après il ya le chronomètre
maintenant on est au micro processeurs
c'est non seulement l'information mais
c'est aussi la fabrication des choses
alors ça il faut que nous intégrons ça
et pour l'instant je pense que nous ne
le faisons pas et nous vivons plus
longtemps
73 ans pour les hommes 82 ans pour les
femmes l'espérance de vie
ça veut dire quatre générations il faut
donc avec une machine mécanique qui va
beaucoup plus vite et bien qu'on arrive
à satisfaire
quatre générations c'est ça le véritable
problème et c'est un problème énorme
mais ça ne peut se faire que par enfin
on peut répondre à la question par deux
choix ou on fait de l'économie
restrictive où on rentre dans une
démarche plus expansive qui s'appelle
l'accroissement de la demande et de la
demande mondiale or je crois que c'est
la voie qu'il nous faut emprunter pour
l'instant tout le monde s'est replié sur
soi et pour l'instant tout le monde
essaie de régler son problème à ce
niveau ce n'est plus possible
et on ne peut faire la queue du
colmatage est des choix des objectifs
essayez de des soucis parce qu'ils ont
50 ans cela parce qu'ils n'ont pas
encore de travailler qu'ils ont 25 ans
mais on ne peut pas on ne relance pas
l'activité économique
ce sens là à ce jour dans l'univers
politique vous n'avez rien entendu de
neuf sur ce sujet ou bien il ya des
choses qui vous paraissent prendre la
bonne direction
je crois que et d'autre part est-ce
qu'on peut ramener ce que vous dites
en termes de conséquences nationales
j'allais dire ici et maintenant à une
politique de relance classique de
relance de la consommation non par la
relance
monsieur pardon monsieur je n'ai pas dis
je pour l'instant je n'ai d'ailleurs pas
parler de relance stricto sensu
c'est l'activité et c'est l'activité
économique et qu'on va commencer par
l'activité industrielle bientôt de la
relance de la consommation est un des
éléments mais ça ne peut pas être le
seul élément ça c'est tout à fait vrai
mais c'est un des éléments et je parle
moi de demande globale
j'introduis lane dans nos rapports
commerciaux avec les pays en
développement les pays en voie
d'industrialisation jeu redéfinit la
notion de clauses sociales plus
sérieusement d'ailleurs que on veut le
laisser croire
j'ai lu l'autre jour que la fuse social
ça serait à ce mythe mondial qu'est ce
que c'est cette aventure intérieure cci
là c'est une aberration c'est pas du
tout ce que nous réclamons bon il faut
qu'il y ait plus des changes tout
simplement pour que tout le monde gagne
plus si j'ose dire et ça c'est possible
nous n'avons pas satisfait tous les
besoins et pour l'instant je ne sens pas
ce discours
même ceux qui disent être partisan d'une
autre politique n'ose pas aller jusque
là
mais avant de parler de cette autre
politique
ce gouvernement tout de même est ce que
vous ne pensez pas qu'il commence à
réussir que quelques signes de réussite
apparaissent ce gouvernement si l'on
s'en tient à ce qu'il a ce qui s étaient
ses objectifs avait dit je voudrais que
l'année 94 soit l'année de la
stabilisation est ce qu'il vous apparaît
que les chiffres chômage bien sûr
puisqu'on parlait principal en du
chômage est-ce qu'il vous apparaît que
les chiffres tels qu'ils tombent mois
après mois depuis le mois de janvier est
maintenant sont effectivement un signe
de stabilisation donc est ce qu est ce
que c'est la bonne direction
est ce que ça vous donne confiance pour
les mois qui viennent ou est-ce qu'au
contraire vous dit non on n'est pas
encore au bond
au niveau bah écoutez je crois qu'il y a
plusieurs éléments qu'il y ait à l'heure
actuelle sur le plan économique après un
assainissement difficile pénible lourd
qui est les prémices d'un réveil une
bonne partie des employeurs le dise j'ai
eu l'occasion de la première c'est avec
eux une partie de l'iss encore que il
faut se méfier des choses s'il s'agit
comme nous le souhaitions de relance et
par la construction la construction de
logements sociaux
c'est important de savoir que les
crédits ont été utilisés ça veut dire
que effectivement il ya une petite
démarche mais attendez avant que ça ne
se généralise c'est autre chose il faut
voir si c'est sectorielles ou cissé
général
deuxièmement je ne suis même pas sûr que
lorsque les indicateurs sociaux comme on
dit maintenant seront tous au vert que
le dynamisme économique reprendra ce je
n'en suis pas du tout persuadé
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à intégrer dans
l'économie vous le savez mieux que moi
notamment le comportement humain et
c'est un des éléments déterminants
l'économie n'est pas une science exacte
alors s'il est vrai que monsieur
balladur qui n'a jamais pris beaucoup de
risques il faut bien le dire peut
apparaître satisfait de la situation ne
se dégrade plus sous réserve d'une
analyse plus détaillée
je crois qu'il peut sa satisfaction peut
peut être être justifiée encore que si
nous parlions du chômage simplement moi
je note quand même que la durée
d'indemnisation est encore plus longues
que par le passé ça veut dire que
maintenant on s'inscrit délibérément
dans un chômage de longue durée
quasi permanent nous dépassons les 370
jours d'indemnisation
là c'est quand même ce qu'on observe
aussi signal particules ce qu'on
l'observé 6 ce qu'on observe aussi c'est
quand il ya des petits signes
d'amélioration même aussi petit soit-il
il s'accompagne d'un regain de
combativité
chez les catégories diverses de salariés
est-ce que vous même vous observez ce
regain de combativité comment
comptez-vous
vous en servir et est ce que vous êtes
toujours de ceux qui attendaient un choc
social
je n'attends pas à chocques sociale je
vais vous dire la vérité si je pouvais
le provoquer je suis provoquerait chez
cei ou régulièrement à la fois
d'informer à la fois de mobiliser et à
la fois d'utiliser les ce que certains
diraient les mécontentements mais qui
sont en fait la forme de l'expression
sous forme de revendications et pour ma
part je n'hésiterai pas à l'utiliser
toutes les fois où c'est nécessaire et
toutes les fois où c'est possible et
c'est pas toujours facile
alors je ne crois pas que pour l'instant
le côté revendicatif l'emportent
parce qu'ils y améliorer sion de la
situation les salariés sont mécontents
ce moment et notamment de la loi
quinquennale sur l'emploi qui est loin
d'être une réussite qui est même une loi
qui détruit l'emploi
au début je disais que j'avais des
réserves sur les postulats d'origine
maintenant à l'expérience elle détruit
d'emplois
l effet c'est le contre est ce qu'il en
reste de cette loi sur l'emploi à
écouter si on arrive si les pattes on
arrive à nous imposer l'annualisation du
temps de travail
ils vont nous faire sortir derrière ça
l'annualisation du salaire
l'annualisation du smic et ils vont
baisser la baisse non pas du coût du
travail mais du salaire brement dit je
crois que comme comme situation c'est
quand même une situation paradoxale
baisse du salaire et pas de relance de
la consommation et balle mais on se
retrouve devant cette situation encore
une fois tout le monde s'interroge
écoutez moi ce que monsieur chirac a dit
j'écoutais ce qu'a dit monsieur bel
adieu j'ai aussi écouté ce qu'a dit
monsieur rocard il aurait pu se
dispenser de porter jugement sur les
syndicats si j'ai l'occasion tout à
l'heure je vais lui répond m mais c'est
clair il semble bien que tout le monde
constate que la politique économique
suivie n'a pas été bonne
et c'est vrai pour ce gouvernement comme
les précédents puisque les prémices ont
été lancées par les autres gouvernements
mais personne n'ose maintenant basculer
complètement alors on va on sent qu'on
cherche des voix mais ça ne bascule pas
mais il faudra que ça m'insulte aux
besoins c'est nous qui irons le chercher
c'est clair merci jean marie colombani
michel noble cour du monde va venir
s'installer est ce que c'est vrai
monsieur blondel que pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de ce pays le
ministre l'actuel ministre du travail
monsieur giraud à un cabinet qui ne
comportent dans ses rangs aucun
inspecteur du travail c'est à dire au
fond aucun spécialiste des questions
qu'ils auraient à traiter et et qu'il
n'ya finalement que là comme ailleurs
que des énarques
oh là là oh la la
non seulement je m'inquiète du fait qu'
il n'y aura pas beaucoup de candidats
aux prochaines élections le candidat
ouvriers dans les listes pour les
élections européennes mais en plus vous
fait remarquer que nos interlocuteurs
sont généralement plutôt des énarques
que des gens spécialisés dans les choses
du travail ça ne veut pas dire que les
génériques ne connaissent quand même pas
leur métier
moi je pense qu'ils le connaissent mais
je ne suis pas sûr effectivement que les
traditions et toujours été bien respecté
et vous parlez du cabinet de monsieur
giraud moi je pense que s'il y avait un
directeur du travail ou un directeur
régional du travail en bonne place comme
à l'accoutumée ça nous permettrait
notamment de dépasser les problèmes de
conflits mais je dois al'inverse dire
que monsieur giraud n'a pas eu beaucoup
de choix
il est arrivé avec une charge énorme en
matière de chômage et son problème c'est
de passer pour monsieur emplois et non
pas monsieur chômage alors il a pris ce
dossier à bras le corps peut être pas
comme nous luttions souhaité et l'appui
à bras le corps et l'essai de s'en
sortir c'est pas facile
moi je voudrais bien c'est pas facile
vous avez vu on l'a mis en échec
quelques fois bon il essaye c'est déjà
quelqu'un qui croit ce qui fait vous
savez c'est important dans un
gouvernement civil dit michel noblecourt
marc blondel bon jour en jour je si j'en
crois votre presse syndicales vous avez
problème est en quelques sorte l'état d'
alerte par rapport aux projets qui sont
en préparation sur la sécurité sociale
la séparation des des risques financiers
entre les quatre caisses du régime
général qui vous inquiète
et puis l'instauration d'un débat annuel
au parlement
sur l'évolution des dépenses de santé
qui est une vieille idée et qui a même
été reprise un temps par françois
mitterrand si je me souviens bien en
décembre 92 il avait évoqué ce projet
alors pour vous expliquer précisément en
quoi le fait de d'introduire cette
séparation des risques financiers de
faire contrôler les dépenses du budget
social de la nation qui sont quand même
plus importante que celle du budget de
l'état par le parlement représente une
menace pour la protection sociale alors
deux observations
première observation en ce qui concerne
la séparation des risques ce que nous ne
voulons pas c'est la séparation des
trésoreries
ce que nous ne voulons pas c'est que
chaque risque doit ce soit dans
l'obligation de s'équilibrer
alors je vais m'expliquer on sait que le
risque allocations familiales est
excédentaire à cette année lorsque
l'assurance maladie a des problèmes dans
la situation présente
on peut affecter de l'argent des
allocations familiales pour passer un
problème de trésorerie sans qu'il y ait
des rapports tels qu'ils soient des
rapports de caractère commerciaux parce
qu'il faut savoir que là aussi pour
avoir de l'argent il faut payer le loyer
de l'argent voire parfois plus ça fait
partie du phénomène de solidarité que
nous souhaitons à partir du moment où on
isole le risque il faut voir ce qu'il y
a dans ce risque et je pense à
l'assurance maladie et je prétends ici
une nouvelle fois publiquement
il n'est pas possible que l'on continue
à affecter au régime d'assurance maladie
toute une série de charges toute une
série de transferts
et puis en faisant simplement constater
qu'il ya un déficit en disant ensuite en
culpabilisant les sages les assujettis
sans dire les raisons du déficit
savez vous que nous sommes incapables de
dire le nombre de fonctionnaires qu'il
ya dans ce pays
pas simplement les gestionnaires de
l'assurance maladie mais monsieur
sarkozy non plus ne peux pas dire le
nombre de fonctionnaires qu'il ya dans
ce pays on ne veut pas le dire pourquoi
tout simplement parce que pour
rembourser la sécurité sociale des
fonctionnaires
prélevez donc par l'état eh bien on fait
ça par raconte successifs on n'arrête
jamais les comptes
les exonérations même problème enfin où
sont pour répondre à la question où sont
les menaces dans les projets actuels de
madame veil -le où sont les menaces dont
nous a été vidée norvège lâché oh non
mais je nique mais je suis en train
d'expliquer la totalité du dossier c'est
que le dossier de l'assurance maladie
est un dossier que l'on alourdi
régulièrement et qui sera déficitaire à
partir du moment où son son analyse et
son équilibre se fait exclusivement sur
ce risque est bien il est clair qu'à un
moment donné nous serons dans
l'obligation de passer la main c'est à
dire de dire où nous baissons les
remboursements ou nous mentons les
cotisations nous n'aurons pas le droit
l'assurance maladie n'aura pas le droit
de décider de l'augmentation des
cotisations et je le vois pas d'ailleurs
pourquoi on prélèverait d'une manière
plus importante les salariés que les
autres maintenant ce qui veut dire que
nous serons en déséquilibre si nous
sommes en déséquilibre constant il est
clair que nous ne pourront plus
rembourser au même niveau et à partir de
ce moment là on passera une partie de la
couverture sociale ou compagnies
d'assurance ou mutuelle et c'est juste
que ça c'est le risque de la sécurité
sociale à deux vitesses selon marc
blondel en maintenant les amène à poser
monsieur blondel tout à l'heure il ya le
fait que vous êtes hostile à ce que le
parlement prenne que c'est votre
deuxième problème relève a répondu parce
que pas la partie de mon le budget
social représente 18 ou bien
démissionner la viande entre 1500 et
1600 milliards le budget social le
budget social c'est à dire y compris les
couvertures complémentaires y compris
l'unedic etc
je suis swing l'état et de 14 14 200
milliards alors bien entendu il ya des
sous et puis à partir du moment aussi où
faut être clair on fait du libéralisme
dans ce pays
pour asseoir son pouvoir on est obligé
de resserrer un peu sûr on fait du
dirigisme sociale donc on va donner la
possibilité aux parlementaires de mettre
en place ou de diriger
les orientations sociales en matière de
protection sociale collective
et bien moi je me sens plus
représentatif qui est un député pour
parler de la chose attendez attendez
laissez moi m'expliquer un député sauf
erreur de ma part il est bien élu par
les français
moi je suis représentatif du mouvement
syndical qui représente l'ensemble des
travailleurs de ce pays qu'ils soient
français ou non et qu'ils soient
cotisants l'on abat oui mais ça non mais
attendez c'est autre chose c'est le
problème du chômage ou si le problème
tenez vous me donnez l'occasion prochain
date et syndicats disent non attendez
chercher autre chose
attendez de neu neu neu regardez bien on
vient de le parlement vient de décider
de transférer il ya quelques jours
enfin quelques semaines les la sécurité
sociale des détenus au régime général
mais pas dire qu'il racontera pas weill
patron pas pareil c'est soixante mille
assujettis supplémentaires et en plus
pardonnez moi une population arich quand
on sait comme ce qui se passe dans les
prisons
on comprend parfaitement et bien en
contrepartie alors que faisons nous
soyons clairs pour le déficit
je voudrais recettes nous allons avoir
en supplément je voudrais revenir sur
les pouvoirs que les gestionnaires de la
protection sociale ont à l'heure
actuelle ce dos quand on parle de la de
l'assurance maladie il y à une tutelle
comme très important drulhe exerçait le
rappel par le gouvernement ruine qui
pour l'essentiel fixe le taux des
cotisations et le montant des
prestations et est ce que vous êtes prêt
vous partenaires sociaux à prendre plus
de responsabilités à prendre plus de
pouvoir dans les caisses donc à exercer
un véritable paritarisme un petit peu ce
que vous faites pour l'assurance chômage
dont l'état n'est pas totalement absent
il l'a encore montré rusé mâcon pisé
mais c'est vous même qui prenait oui
décision finalement est ce que vous êtes
prêt à jouer ce jeu de la responsable
oui sous réserve que nous obtenions avec
la clarification des comptes en soit
bien au clair que nous obtenions que
l'on précise aux gens très clairement où
sont les charges alors là nous pourrions
effectivement essayé de dominer la
gestion du risque de l'assurance maladie
pour le régime général
mais alors il faut pas hésiter à dire
telle catégorie que je ne veux pas citer
parce que je ne veux pas dans
avec mes amis telle catégorie qui verse
19 % monsieur noblecourt vous verrez
immédiatement ces agriculteurs 19 % de
ce qu'il dépense ne peuvent pas
consentir une cotisation et un
prélèvement aussi importante les
salariés alors c'est la solidarité
nationale qui se substituent et moi je
suis d'accord y compris pour payer
l'impôt
pour eux la solidarité nationale face se
substitue aux impossibilités des
exploitants agricoles puisqu'il s'agit
des exploiteurs l'école parce que je
souhaite que les exploitants agricoles
soient soignés comme les autres ça c'est
tout à fait clair
alors justement il ya le problème plus
global du financement de la protection
sociale qui est assurée à l'heure
actuelle à 90% par les par les
cotisations on se trouve avec un régime
général de sécurité sociale d'éducation
très difficile 100 milliards de déficit
pour 94 et 95 93 et 94
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
relancer la réflexion sur ce financement
de la protection sociale est ce qu'il
faut avoir une autre assiette que celle
des salaires est ce qu'il faut prévoir
un recours accru par exemple à la tva
une idée qui était un petit peu dans
l'air ces derniers temps puis à peu
abandonnée si vous êtes une idée qui a
été perverti l'histoire de la tva
sociale c'était pas du tout pour nous on
en voulait l'affecté plus ou moins à la
politique de l'emploi
oh non les exonérations nommé justement
ça nous renvoie alors ça ça nous
conduirait seine conduit à l'avenir la
tva sociale c'était une idée c'était une
tva sur les produits d'importation de
manière à aider les pays en voie de
développement ou en voie
d'industrialisation à mettre debout un
régime de sécurité sociale cds à l'idée
au débat et puis après on a dit ben si
on a des sous il faut mieux pour les
utilisent pour nous mêmes puisque nous
sommes en déficit c'est ça la démarche
ceci étant mon problème c'est que je
suis contre la fiscalisation ça c'est
évident
sinon je ne soutiendrai pas que les
députés ne sont pas aussi fondées que
cela à mettre leur nez dans nos affaires
mais parce que je veux légitimer la
position des organisations syndicales et
leurs expressions à l'intérieur de ces
régimes sociaux par ses cotisations et
pas pour l'impôt c'est ça mais ma faveur
sur la
cotisation plus que l'impôt ce qui veut
dire que ça justifie reims atteindre
sans exclure notamment je le dis quand
je dis solidarité nationale ça veut dire
que ça c'est l'impôt c'est clair alors
sans exclure la possibilité notamment
pour les régimes qui ne sont pas le
régime général et qui sont en déficit en
déficit de manière à ce que in fine et
on retrouve un équilibre
alors je dis tout de suite parce que je
sais que des idées je ne suis pas non
plus pour une gestion du budget social
de la nation qui pourrait être attribué
à un espèce de comité économique et
social parce que là je pense que compte
tenu de l'importance des fonds nous
aurions à participer à la gestion de
l'état
et ça je ne souhaite pas pour les
organisations syndicales qu'il en soit
ainsi
alors prenons prenons un dossier
important de la protection sociale qui
est celui des retraites le gouvernement
engagé une réforme qui s'applique depuis
le 1er janvier 94 et qui va conduire
notamment à ce que en 2005 en 2003 est
ce nécessaire d'avoir 160 trimestres de
cotisation pour pouvoir prendre sa
retraite et qu'en 2008
eh bien on prennent comme référence pour
le calcul de cette retraite les 25
meilleures années au lieu des 10 jusqu'à
lors pour affronter la baisse
démographique 2005 2010 où les
générations de l'après-guerre vont
arrivées à l'âge de la retraite on sait
que ce ne sera pas suffisant par rapport
à l'effort qu'il va falloir consentir
pour financer les retraites dans cette
d'ici cette date qu'est ce que vous
proposez pour venir à vous retrouver
pour proposer des comme solution pour
venir à bout de cette difficulté ce
qu'il faut continuer à augmenter
inlassablement les prélèvements est ce
qu'il faut recourir à la contribution
sociale généralisée
est ce qu'il faut toucher aux
prestations et ce qu'il faut
éventuellement faire plus recourir
davantage à des systèmes de
capitalisation quel est votre schéma sur
les retraites
avez-vous des je crois que c'est très
clair la première chose c'est que je
suis tout à fait hostile à la remise en
cause du niveau des retraites à la fois
l'allongement du temps nécessaire à la
cotisation à la fois le passage
10 à 25 meilleures années ça a un effet
terrible sur le niveau des retraites
nous disions à l'époque 10 à 12% or
maintenant semble-t-il les chiffres y
étant affiné ça peut aller jusqu'à 15 et
16% de retraite en moins et la déflation
sur les prix aussi jazy j indique l'umih
l'indexation sur les prix c'est autre
chose est également à l'examen ce
mécanique un bon nom mais l'indexation
sur les prix c'est autre chose là on
peut toujours mobiliser les gens c'est
comme les problèmes de salaires que j'ai
peur c'est les règlements qui dure et
j'indique au passage que en corollaire
les régimes de retraites complémentaires
ont eux aussi été révisée à la baisse
et je pense que nous avons demandé
beaucoup aux retraités et je pense
d'ailleurs qu'ils avaient quelques
droits à faire valoir
alors il me semble que s'il ya une
nouvelle baisse à passer il faut trouver
un financement qui viennent d'un autre
moyen c'est-à-dire la bombe n'a beau on
ne pourra pas continuer à pressurer
comme ça les droits des retraités
on n'acceptera pas d'augmenter les
cotisations
on connaît bien les problèmes que nous
avons eus avec la retraite
complémentaire on connaît bien la
situation des employeurs la position des
employeurs en ce moment je ne crois pas
que nous pourrons aller autrement sauf à
une intervention de solidarité qui
pourrait venir dans le fond pourquoi pas
l'affectation aussi d'une privatisation
d'un établissement parce qu'en
définitive il ya aucune raison de le
fonds de garantie des actifs auxquels
avait songé pierre bérégovoy en
affectant effectivement les actifs
publics est là au financement de la
retraite
je ne voulais peut-être pas le dire
aussi directement mais vous avez conclu
pour moi mais dont le fond pourquoi pas
ça prouvait que pierre bérégovoy avait
là dessus une réflexion qui n'était pas
une mauvaise réflexion pourquoi les
salariés même retraités ne bénéficierait
pas du patrimoine national quand on vend
une une entreprise
nationaliser qui appartenait à l'état
pourquoi que ça pour quelle raison ça
n'aiderait pas à financer les régimes
sociaux et en particulier entre toutes
petites valeurs vraiment toute petite
dernière il y en avait beaucoup d'autres
non simplement nous sommes le 1er mai
donc effectivement ça pose la question
des relations avec les autres syndicats
et en france ont toujours l'impression
que chacun cultive ses particularismes
que cultive un petit peu sa division
vous êtes un petit peu isolé ce qui
donne à l'extérieur je dirais dans les
autres pays européens une mauvaise image
du syndicalisme français qui est un peu
le petit poucet déjà de l'europe et qui
en plus passe son temps à se les uns et
les autres passent leur temps à se
battre lorsque vous pensez que vous et
faire des efforts pour redresser cette
image est peut-être pendant un peu plus
de coopération à l'intérieur du mais
avec les autres syndicats
monsieur double cours pardonnez moi mais
en ce qui concerne l'image
laissez-moi juge je fréquente
certainement autant certaines routes
dans le mouvement syndical international
et européen que vous êtes arrivé le fait
qu alors oui oui non mais je ne conteste
pas le fait que vous les voyez seulement
je crois qu'il faut pas l'image du
syndicalisme français n'est pas aussi
mauvais que ça devrais je rappeler que
je suis vice-président de la cis elle
devrait rappeler que je suis membre du
comité de direction des crs et que le
mouvement syndical français est
parfaitement respectée je dirais même
mieux en ce moment au sein de la csl
notamment sur l'indépendance syndicale
ce sont nos idées qui sont reprises sur
la clause sociale ce sont nos idées qui
ont été reprises alors je ne croyais moi
et si vous me permettez monsieur de
virieu monsieur frizot le
secrétaire-général de la csl et gabaglio
le secrétaire général de la crs devait
être là ils sont paraît-il ne réussit à
passer à sarajevo
je devais d'ailleurs aller avec eux
c'est votre aimable invitation il m'a
fait rester ici ce qui veut dire que le
mouvement syndical français est
considéré contrairement à ce qu'on peut
affirmer maintenant soyons gentils la
pluralité syndicale en france est un
phénomène historique à des réseaux bon
est ce que ces raisons change
est ce que monsieur le secrétaire
général de la cgt n'est toujours
n'est-il pas encore membre du bureau
politique du parti communiste
bon c'est pas le fait qu'il fasse une
déclaration avec monsieur rocard sur
l'indépendance qui changera quoi que ce
soir bon ça veut donc dire que moi je ne
ferais pas
je ne ferai pas des manifestations
unitaires qui sont des manifestations de
symboles avec des gens qui n'ont pas les
mêmes objectifs que moi pour le
mouvement syndical
il peut arriver que dans l'action nous
soyons amenés à faire des actions
communes cet autre chose mais le 1er mai
a justement une valeur symbolique que je
ne veux pas dévoyé et je ne voudrais pas
être trop méchant mais il ya encore
quelques années il me semble qu on
défilait au pas de l'oie dans certains
endroits
alors c'est quand même sérieux et je ne
vous bousculez pas comme ça le paysage
syndical pour satisfaire un 1er mai
unitaire c'est beaucoup trop dangereux
merci à michel noblecourt albert du roy
où va éclater le prochain conflit social
en france
ces hôpitaux les hôpitaux parce que la
sécurité sociale les hôpitaux parce que
le budget global les hôpitaux parce
qu'on n'a pas utilisée correctement les
fonds qui ont été attribués et me dit oh
parce qu'on n'a pas mis en place une
veille de salaire que nous n'avons pas
signé nous la trouvons enfin de
classification que nous trouvions
mauvaise ce qui fait qu'on a utilisé
l'argent pour autre chose et que les
salariés sont mécontents là-dessus
madame veil annonce de manière aveugle
qu'on va supprimer 24000 dit sans
expliquer d'ailleurs les analyses pour
arriver à ce chiffre
moralité tout le monde est mécontent ça
va bientôt éclater ce que je souhaite
c'est que ce soit les organisations
syndicales qui domine le conflit parce
que si on a encore le droit aux
coordinations on n'a pas fini de nous
expliquer que nous sommes sur le point
d'être de rendre l'âme alors dans
l'affairé au clair
c'est nous qui prendront d'ailleurs le
17 mai nous partons en guerre s'est dit
bonjour monsieur durand d'elle un tout
petit retour en arrière d'abord
vous jouez bien noté vous voulez être
juge de l'image des syndicats j'étais
comme une frappe et devrait connaître
votre réaction
ce sondage qui a été publiée cette
semaine dans le nouvel observateur et
sur la chaîne arte et à la question à
qui faites-vous le plus confiance pour
lutter contre le chômage en france il ya
d'abord les associations puis les chefs
d'entreprise puis les coordinations puis
le gouvernement et seulement après les
syndicats il n'y a que l'organisation
qui est derrière ces les partis
politiques
moi je trouve que c'est bien c'est bien
enfin ça conforte l'image des syndicats
non non non mais je trouve que c'est
bien mais que voulez-vous à une question
idiote réponse idiote et la réponse est
idiote monsieur la question est idiote
enfin c'est bien clair est ce que les
syndicats dans ce pays où l'autorité
pour créer des emplois vous a vu le
savent où il ya deux endroits le
patronat et la politique économique et
même le patronat quand on lui donne la
responsabilité dit c'est pas moi c'est
la politique économique
comment expliquez-vous et bien entendu
on fait un sondage alors aujourd'hui les
syndicats
comment expliquez moi j'ai aucun pouvoir
pour que comme c'est parfois la chance
de pouvoir me battre pour empêcher qu'on
leur supprime et on m'écoute pas tout le
temps comment expliquez-vous qu'à la
même question en allemagne les syndicats
arrivent en tête parce que les syndicats
n'ont pas la même fonction d'albane
parce que les syndicats ont accepté de
participer beaucoup plus à la gestion du
pays et alors et alors c'est un
mouvement à suivre pourquoi ah bon non
mais ça marche là-bas ça ne marche pas
ici mais il faut continuer à faire
pourquoi tous les points comme les
autres ça marche mieux
non mais attendez si ça marche mieux
vous avez vous un marché vieux attendez
attendez monsieur du roi qu'on parle
bien le même langage sauf erreur de ma
part
y'a pas quelques problèmes en allemagne
il problème partout via pas à bon y'a
pas quelques difficultés le mouvement
syndical du fait qu'il est plus
participant à la gestion de l'entreprise
n'a pas de temps en temps quelques
grandes difficultés vous imaginez le
secrétaire général d'une organisation
syndicale que vous avez devant vous
étant en même temps le vice-président de
chez renault mais globale n mal an
globalement vous n'avez pas sur mes amis
de chez volkswagen ont pu bloquer le
licenciement globalement globalement
vous n'avez pas le sentiment que le
système peut être qu'il est inapplicable
en france que le système syndical
la cogestion en allemagne a obtenu de
meilleurs résultats que la lutte des
classes en france ne le crois pas mais
je pourquoi dit-on du décret d'une des
classes à vous employer les grands mots
et ces retrouvailles pas le premier
reconnaissons qu'il y ait des classes ne
parlait pas de lui tout au moins pas de
lutte permanente
c'est intéressant ce faux pas on n'est
pas tous les jours avec les couteaux non
mais qu'on se comprenne bien je ne crois
pas du tout que l'on puisse faire une
comparaison entre les deux pays
parce que nous n'appartenons pas je
dirais nous n'avons pas la même
appréhension des choses alors c'est trop
facile de dire en allemagne de ça marche
maintenant l'allemagne a bénéficié de
toute une série de choses
au lendemain de la guerre elle a eu
beaucoup de choses
enfin je pourrais rappelé qu'elle
n'avait pas le droit d'avoir un armement
donc elle consacrée sur l'argent autre
chose que les américains ouvrait les
vannes parce qu'il fallait montrer
justement à l'allemagne de l'est qu'on
pouvait faire beaucoup mieux et c'est
dur vers l'europe et blanc dès lors on
va mal et va faire l'europe attendait
mais laissez moi quand vous terminez ont
tout refait toutes les dernières
comparaisons stupides c'est sur le
chômage et sur les jeunes on a 10 x % en
france et puis regardez oui sauf si on
fait le calcul 25% fort ce matin entre
22 et 26 ans sauf si on fait le calcul
normalement c'est à dire qu'on ramène sa
très exactement entre le nombre de
chômeurs la tranche d'âge et la
population et là on voit tout simplement
que wire pas tellement d'écart dans le
chômage des jeunes entre la france puis
bon et puis l'allemand va on va parler
de l'europe et du monde dans quelques
instants mais j'ai cru comprendre tout à
l'heure que vous aviez quelque chose à
dire à propos de michel rocard alors je
vais vous donner l'occasion de le dire
oui enfin vous me présentez les choses
j'ai entendu
c'est vrai michel rocard dire hier qu'
il fallait aider les syndicats à sortir
du ghetto de la défense des salariés
ayant un emploi
je crois que monsieur michel rocard
confond les genres une organisation
syndicale qui abandonnerait la
revendication pour ceux qui ont un
contrat de travail ferait un autre fils
le mouvement syndical
si c'est pour nous faire nous
culpabiliser afin que nous ne
sollicitons pas où nous revendiquions
pas d'augmentation de salaire parce
qu'il ya des chômeurs il ya longtemps
que cette hypothèse-là été analysés dans
nos milieux et que nous savons que ça ne
change rien bien au contraire
escape a quand même un bien fou devrait
opposer le plus grand danger que nous
ayons s'est opposé les salariés qui ont
un emploi à ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
parce que ils sont interchangeables
celui qui a un emploi aujourd'hui le
jour où il est en colère avec celui qui
n'a pas d'emploi est en colère et que
celui qui a un emploi
la solution c'est tout simplement de
prendre l'emploi et puis c'est l'autre
qui n'en n'aura pas ça ne change
rigoureusement rien lorsque vous êtes
venus ici dans cette émission il ya un
tout petit peu plus d'un an vous notiez
vous même que les travailleurs qui
perdent leur emploi
ce s'éloignait du mouvement
d'indignation bon il y a un vrai
problème dans la mesure où c'est vrai
que vous devez représenter des salariés
donc a priori les gens qui ont un emploi
et que du coup vous risquez de ne pas
prendre en compte autant qu'ils le
voudraient eux les chômeurs ses soutiens
d'aubry ici dans cette émission a
souhaité de l'agression d'un des quatre
chemins
oui mais d'abord il a souhaité quelque
chose qui existait depuis longtemps
depuis très longtemps très longtemps
monsieur paga existe depuis très
longtemps et je fais pas de publicité
pour bagarre mais maintenant il y en a
d'autres
puis ce qui est intéressant de voir
c'est que ça marche pas et c'est très
bien la syrie mais alors comme ceux-ci
ring quand tu vas faire face aux besoins
des ennuis dans l'est face aux besoins
qui est ce qui va négocier ti a fait les
sacrifices en matière de financement de
l'unedic pour les chômeurs
l'augmentation des cotisations
ce sont ceux qui ne travaillent pas qui
les paye c'est bien ceux qui travaillent
ça c'est un phénomène de solidarité
lorsque je lève le ton et jeudi on
prélève 20% sur les fonctionnaires ce 1%
il doit revenir dans la caisse de l'une
et de l'unedic je défends pas les
chômeurs
allons allons allons je pense que je
fais plus pour les chômeurs que tous
ceux qui font du bruit pour avoir des
subventions
vous n'avez pas du tout le fait le
reproche qu'on entend dans chez certains
et peut-être chez michel rocard le
reproche qui est fait parfois au
syndicat qui est de défendre les
situations acquises pour ne pas
reprendre la formule habituelle des
avantages à gré d'ab ce n'est pas vrai
bon pour vous savez écouter vous êtes
très manichéen aujourd'hui non mais
soyons de régler les gains de rang que
se posent les gens soyons très clairs
d'abord les situations acquises
si on fait le bilan est là je fais
l'averse de ce que je devrais faire je
valorise pas l'action des syndicats
ça fait quelques temps que nous sommes
en train de faire de l'auto défense
vous savez le rôle du syndic en ce
moment c'est bien souvent de tenir la
mêlée pour pas se faire défoncer à c'est
plutôt ça on n'est pas très conquérant
il faut quand même être clair bon c'est
clair et c'est aussi peut-être pour ça
qu on ne recrute pas autant suis navré
ceci étant c'est notre rôle et il faut
que le faire parce que c'est ce qui fait
la nécessité économique
le fait que nous demandions des choses
crée le mouvement
forte heureusement sinon par définition
tout ça ça va s'effriter ma s'effilocher
et ça ne donnera rien aux autres
le véritable problème c'est que
notamment le fait que le syndicat soit
de plus en plus localisés dans
l'entreprise fait que celui qui est
licencié
on lui ferme aussi la porte syndicale
dans le temps il allait à la bourse du
travail
maintenant ils y vont de moins en moins
quand ils sont licenciés et n'ont plus
de contact avec le syndicat que nous
ayons nous un problème là de démarches
vis-à-vis de ces de ses camarades là oui
il ya un problème de démarche
il faut y aller il ya un problème la
démarche aussi vers les jeunes
mais ça vous ne pouvez pas me faire le
procès de ne pas miser est rendue je
peux revendique bien entendu le smic
jeunes et l'action qui a été menée avec
tes étudiants et les lycéens
il faudrait sélectionné sévèrement les
questions qui restent à poser parce
qu'il reste peu de temps
est ce que vous avez en face de vous
vous interlocuteur syndicales le
patronat représentatif que vous
souhaitez nous avons un petit problème
avec le patronat en ce moment où le
savez bien c'est dû à deux raisons
vraisemblablement le départ de monsieur
perrigault ton qui sont en période
électorale ou pré électorale et ça n'est
jamais le mieux et puis il ya eu
effectivement je leur est reproché ils
nous ont invités l'autre jour à un
colloque
je leur est reproché les patrons étaient
surpris vraisemblablement de la durée de
la crise et les problèmes sociaux sont
devenus une gêne pour eux et ils ont
délégué notamment aux sociétés de
consultation en participant en
particulier est consultant et je sais
moi que l'on faisait des séminaires à
bruxelles et consultant où il y avait
toute une série d'entreprises qui était
représenté que nous ne retrouvions même
pas au cnpf
ce qui veut dire que social est écarté
de la gestion de l'entreprise et le cnpf
recense à un peu indirectement
maintenant mais j'ai l'impression qu'ils
sont entendus sur ses erreurs a
contrario quand on voit un patron celui
d'air france
sauter par dessus des syndicats pour
interroger directement le personnel est
pas loin de me dire ça à moi que vous
avez appuyé ennuyé à voter non pas du
tout je constate et vous n'avez pas le
droit de me dire ça puisque alors il
faudrait j'ai droit de vous le dire vous
avez le droit de ne pas être d'accord
avec moi je ne suis pas d'accord
monsieur du roi et je n'aime pas ne pas
être d'accord avec monsieur du roi
explique explique jean echenoz mais
c'est très important très important air
france nous représentons 38 pour son air
france c'est nous qu'ils en sont la
grève du 12 octobre
c'est nous qu'ils arrêtent aussi
nonobstant les petites fantaisies et les
c'est nous qui prenons nos
responsabilités
ça pourrait fait ça n'était pas l'objet
ce n'était pas le but le changement de
président le président qui arrive lui ne
demande pas une société de consultation
société andersen monsieur attali et il
essaye de voir avec les intéressés
comment on peut sortir de l'ornière
on va chercher va milliards on en
espérait même un petit peu plus on
essaye de sauver la compagnie il fait
des propositions
ces propositions sont contestables mais
le syndicat fo fait une consultation de
ses adhérents
ensuite le syndicat fo dima nous on est
d'accord monsieur
ici en blanc dit c'est pas suffisant il
me faut toutes les organisations
syndicales c'est peut-être sa
coquetterie
il les a cédées est ça qu il l'a dépassé
il a dépassé sa coquetterie et il a un
résultat satisfaisant au référendum je
dis bien qu'il mesure bien toute
l'importance qu'il a maintenant non
seulement il a la confiance de l'état
mais il a contraint et forcé les gens à
lui à cordis ci fait une erreur il peut
prendre un billet pour la guyane où le
brésil ça je vous le certifie ils vont
le vide et à coups de fourche 6 trompent
parce qu'il ya une espèce de délégations
morale que jamais aucun patron n'aura eu
mais ne croyez surtout pas que les
patrons doivent prendre ça comme modèle
il est sur le fil
la meilleure preuve c'est que les
salariés des méridiens qui appartiennent
à air france le revendique un référendum
parce qu'ils veulent rester dans le
groupe air france et là on leur donnera
pas un référendum peut pas gérer par
référendum
on peut pas gérer par oui ou par non et
on ne peut pas déborder les
organisations syndicales qui va gérer le
plan maintenant tu y vas dire demain
nous sommes en désaccord pour que vous
fermiez tel service c'est bien les
syndicats vous en faites pas on risque
avant peu de se retrouver avec une grève
et on ira encore une fois que nous
bloquons l'économie de la france
remercie
c'est frais c'est donc l'heure de vérité
de monsieur marc blondel secrétaire
général de force ouvrière
la semaine prochaine nous reprenons nos
débats sur les enjeux de l'élection
européenne invité monsieur alain
lamassoure ministre délégué aux affaires
européennes face à monsieur jean pierre
chevènement ancien ministre socialiste
qui conduira la liste
l'autre politique pour l'élection du
parlement européen a alors avant de vous
quitter je voudrais vous dire deux mots
de ce magazine 100 photos pour la
liberté de la presse c'est édité par
reporters sans frontières au profit des
familles de journalistes qui ont été
tués l'an dernier dans l'exercice de
leur métier il y en a eu 63 93 dont 14
tout près de nous en algérie s'est vendu
38 francs et 60 mille exemplaires ont
été vendus en 93 j'espère qu'on fera
mieux cette année
bon dimanche bon défilé si vous suivez
les consignes sénégal sept syndicalistes
ont été tuées en 81
c'est d'une précision importante victime
entre à apporter merci monsieur blondel
bon dimanche et bonne semaine à tous
[Musique]